United States has announced a
significant breakthrough in the Quest
for nuclear fusion energy after more
than 60 years of research for the first
time a fusion experiment has produced
more energy than was used to start the
process its hope that further
development occurred one day create an
inexhaustible source of clean energy
Fusion involves the same process that
gives the sun its energy but experts are
warning that it'll be many years before
the technology is ready for commercial
use
well the Breakthrough was announced by
the head of the U.S energy Department
Jennifer granholm
uh today we're here to talk about Fusion
combining two particles into one
last week at the Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory in California
scientists at the national ignition
facility achieved Fusion ignition
and that is creating more energy from
Fusion reactions than the energy used to
start the process
it's the first time it has ever been
done in a laboratory
anywhere in the world
simply put this is one of the most
impressive scientific Feats of the 21st
Century
let's look at this with Dr Athena capati
who's a research scientist in this field
at the Max Planck Institute for plasma
physics here in Germany welcome to DW
are you excited about this announcement
oh absolutely there's a few Fusion
scientists one can only be excited about
such nice news
and why what is it about this that is so
phenomenal
well any progress in Fusion research is
very important to all of us so of course
in Fusion we're trying to produce clean
abundant energy we're trying to provide
this to the world as an option because
we know we're all looking for a
carbon-free clean safe source of energy
and this is becoming more and more
important as we are progressing in in
this century and it will become even
more important in the coming years so we
are trying very hard as you've heard
before for many decades to do this so
any news of success both like the one
announced by uh by the nif lab today and
also news that we've discussed we've
announced in the magnetic confinement
Fusion earlier this year are actually
very encouraging that we're getting
closer and closer to this goal okay
explain to us then if you can in
layman's terms what Fusion is and how it
produces all this abundant clean energy
exactly so a fusion is the process in
which we're trying to combine two very
light nuclei into a heavier one so by
combining these two nuclei together we
have the release of energy as you heard
before this is the process that powers
up our sun and the goal is to try to
mimic this here on Earth this is not an
easy task as you can imagine as in the
sun it's very hot we need also very high
temperatures also here on Earth so to
make this Fusion reactions work we have
to reach temperatures of about 150
million degrees this is non-negligible
and there are many approaches to do that
so one of them is what we said before
magnetic confinement Fusion so we are
trying to contain our Fusion fuel with
magnetic fields this is where for
example we're working on here in Germany
also in the jet facility in the UK but
there's also the inertial confinement
Fusion approach which is what this
achievement today was announced and
which are trying to very powerful lasers
to compress the fuel to reach the
conditions needed for for these Fusion
reactions to happen to produce the heat
which we can then this next step turn
into electricity okay I've been taking
notes we're going to have a test later
does this technology have any downside
in 200 years will we be going through a
similar process of regret as we're going
through now with carbon-based fuels
none that we can see in the sense that
we are not only promising something that
is carbon free but we're talking about
missing something that is safe we don't
have any long-lived radioactive waste we
know that this can is we have a fuel
that is abundant we can get both our
deuterium and tritium these are the
light nuclei that we want to fuse
together to get the energy out this is
this is also available so we do believe
and we can show that it's possible to
have this as a abundant source of energy
that can cover the demands we are having
and will have even more in the future so
once this is commercially scalable is it
likely to be The Preserve of only the
Richer countries
so as you said very well these it's the
scalability and how to make it
commercially available that is the trick
here uh as you've heard uh also from the
scientists at nif or you can hear is
that this is a long-term process this is
very demanding we're working for years
and I share the feeling of the
scientists announcing the results of the
perseverance required for this
um our goal is to make this scalable to
make it financially
possible but of course it is at the end
for the society and for the politics to
receive this as an option the idea is of
course that by offering this option no
matter where it takes place it does
relieve the demand it does make it
better play made a better solution for a
planet than for our issues so I want to
believe that as scientists our job is to
provide this option for society to take
over okay well we wish you well in your
endeavors thank you so much for for
joining us Dr Athena capatu from the Max
Planck Institute
thank you
thank you for having me